again welcome to Tucker Carlson said
happy Friday it's pretty hard to argue
with people who are passive aggressive
you may have tried it before why are you
so angry they scream stop being violent
they snarl as they punch you in the face
passive aggressive people are intent on
dominating you but they're too dishonest
to admit it now it's not an honorable
style of attack but it's very effective
mostly because it's so bewildering the
Democratic party practice is this
Democrats will never meet you on an open
field of battle instead they will sneak
up behind you and knock you unconscious
with a bag of sanctimony
this is the party of weak men and angry
women so passive aggression is their
only mode of communication if you've
ever seen one of jensaki's press
conferences you know exactly what we're
talking about we watched one of them
yesterday in fact it was her last
Peter Ducey asked sake what the
administration thinks of the fact that
liberal groups have posted the home
addresses of conservative Supreme Court
Justices on the internet now why they're
doing this well it's obvious why they're
doing it and no one denies why they're
doing it they're doing it in order to
frighten those justices into changing
their votes on Roe v Wade now that's
illegal it's very clearly a federal
crime it's also by the way the road to
chaos and collapse you can't allow angry
mobs to make your country's laws that's
why we banned lynching
but jensaki did not have a problem with
this people are understandably upset
with Sam alito's views she said so you
shouldn't be surprised they want to
express that concern in person by
screaming at samuelito and his family
quote I don't have an official U.S
government position on where people
should protest
really jensaki are those the rules now
how would you feel if angry protesters
showed up outside say Michelle Obama's
house
of course they'd be thrown into thumb
screws within minutes and charged with
racism and you would applaud as they
languished in jail
but conservative Supreme Court Justices
no that's a different story because
conservative Supreme Court Justices
deserve it that's jensaki's position but
it is not in fact since we've speaking
of this topic the official position of
the US government no according to 18 U.S
code 1507 the official position of the
US government is you're not allowed to
intimidate judges period quote whoever
with the intent of interfering with
obstructing or impeding the
administration of justice or with the
intent of influencing any judge juror
witness or court officer in the
discharge of his duty pickets or parades
in or near a building housing a court of
the United States or in or near a
building or residence occupied or used
by such judge juror witness or court
officer or with such intent uses any
soundtrack or similar device or resorts
to any other demonstration in or near
any such building or residence shall be
fined or imprisoned
so it's very clearly a crime jensaki
either didn't know this or far more
likely didn't care because as far as the
Biden Administration is concerned
Justice Alito is responsible for the
threats against his family if you want
to be targeted by a mob then don't write
opinions the mob doesn't like Dumbo you
did this to yourself it's your fault
we're hurting you
that's always the position of passive
aggressive people and it's the position
of the passive aggressive party so we
recognized it immediately because we
watch our stuff for a living
and then we saw this and it made us
think this ran on CNN this morning now
for days we have assumed based on quite
a bit of evidence that the main threat
to Supreme Court Justices right now into
our justice system itself comes from
groups of activist liberals who are
enraged by the idea that Roe v Wade
might be repealed these are the people
who are spray painting churches and
putting samuelito's home address on the
internet
they're the mob and they're angry and we
know why they're angry so the whole
thing made sense to us
but according to Cena that's not what's
happening in fact it's the opposite of
what's happening the real threat CNN
informed us this morning comes not from
people who were angry about Sam alito's
opinion but from people who are happy
about it
so the ones who are celebrating what Sam
Alito wrote are the ones who are the
real danger to the Supreme Court watch
this morning law enforcement officials
are preparing for potential violence in
the capital and Nationwide after the
leak of that Supreme Court draft opinion
that would strike down Roe v Wade after
50 years Capitol Police are warning the
far right is calling for violence
against a religious group planning to
Rally four abortion rights Whitney Wilde
is live outside the Supreme Court
listen seeing fences go up there it's
sort of like Post January 6. what are
you seeing and what specific
intelligence is warring if police
officials
well at this point law enforcement
sources several of them tell us that
they are closely monitoring social media
chatter uh that suggests that there's a
potential for violence against abortion
clinic providers abortion clinic staff
members of the Judiciary that would
include the justices here as well as
members of the federal government and
what we know after January 6th and what
law enforcement knows across the country
is that social media chatter can
manifest into actual violence sometimes
people really do say what they're going
to do
you got that law enforcement sources
tell CNN the real threat here is the far
right on the far right fences are going
up outside the Supreme Court because the
far right poses a threat the far right
is the one you have to watch out for
they're the ones whose electronic
communications you've got to quote
monitor closely and that makes sense now
that Roe v Wade may be going away these
people are going to want to bomb as many
abortion clinics as they can and hurt as
many Supreme Court justices as possible
after all the Supreme Court may get rid
of a law that they have hated for 50
years so you can see why they'd be moved
to violence against the Supreme Court
now our first response to this was to
laugh it seemed too absurd to be real
how dumb do they think we are and then
we remembered what the president of the
United States and his attorney general
have been telling us for more than a
year
they've been telling us that no matter
what happens no matter what it may look
like the people who did it didn't vote
for us
yeah the people who didn't vote for us
are the Dangerous Ones it's always their
fault watch
I have not seen a more dangerous threat
to democracy than the invasion of the
capital the greatest terrorism-related
threat that we face in the Homeland is
the threat of domestic violent extremism
according to the intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal threat to the Homeland today
not Isis not Al Qaeda White supremacists
not Al Qaeda
white supremacy
so we reviewed those tapes it started to
make sense like the Mongols and the
Visigoths before them these dreaded
white supremacists have declared war on
civilization these Trump voters and the
evidence that is all around us we've
just ignored it because in some level we
don't want to know
but in retrospect it was always right in
front of us you recall when Trump voters
looted that Macy's in New York City they
couldn't help themselves that's who they
are then they torched a police precinct
in Minneapolis the very symbol of the
law they set it on fire and then they
burned a federal building in Portland
Oregon
in case you've forgotten what all of
these right-wing attacks looked like
from White supremacists here's what they
did
[Applause]
[Music]
got it
Beyond
she can see why they're putting up
barriers in front of the Supreme Court
those people are so happy with Sam
alito's opinion they might start burning
and looting again and of course that
would be consistent with the years-long
reign of right-wing Terror we've been
living through because their thirst for
Anarchy and chaos is never sated at one
point these Trump voters seceded from
the United States they set up their own
nation of lawlessness drugs and squalor
and violence within the very city limits
of Seattle just like the Confederates of
1861 but with more weed and spray paint
right in the middle of Seattle talk
about Brazen but that's who they are
that could happen in your town no wonder
America's abortionist Community is
cowering in fear tonight and it gets
worse these maggot people have so little
respect for Law and Order they think
nothing of rushing into Buildings
Department Stores Walgreens liquor
stores Foot Locker and just taking what
they want
they steal armfuls of merchandise off
the shelves and walk out the door like
it's theirs and then purely to amuse
themselves they push strangers in front
of trains and open fire and subway cars
they drive trucks through Christmas
parades and beat elderly Asian women on
the street
you can't control these people because
they're beyond the reach of logic they
are so primitive and superstitious they
have come to believe they can defeat
nature itself with magic amulets like
cosmetics and women's clothing they
think they're shape shifters you can
change their physical form at will
there's become something different
you're seeing one on your screen right
now people like this don't believe in
history or science they're barely
literate so they communicate instead in
Grunts and unintelligible sounds here's
the leader the chief of their tribe
speaking in a language only they can
understand
so the best way to get something done if
you if you hold near and dear to you
that you like to be able to
anyway
thank you
what did he just say we don't know you'd
have to be right supremacist Maga person
to understand it's an esoteric language
these Primitives Adorn their bodies with
fantastic decorations they dress in
costume some even push pieces of metal
through their faces in order to look
Fierce look at them in their warpaint
Madison I'm a preschool
recently we started
all day and we had some that changed up
so I'm a non-binary preschool teacher
and my kids know I'm non-binary they
know I'm not a girl or a boy I use they
them pronouns in the classroom we work
on it not all the kids get it that's
okay and I go by mixed gray in the
classroom not miss or Mr Man y'all
thought me teaching the children about
me being Paulie was crazy but not only
that but they also know that I'm gender
fluid I'm gonna give you my explanation
about what it means to be transgender as
well so when babies are born the doctor
looks at them and they make a guess
about whether the baby is a boy or a
girl it's as young as three and four are
actually aware of their gender identity
even if they don't have the language for
it say that pre-k through third grade
are not ready for such topics is
actually internalized homophobia and
transphobia
Margaret Mead wrote about people like
this anti-social elements that are a
feature of any society but in our case
the Maga people number in the millions
you saw just a few on your screen and
because there are so many they threaten
the very foundations of our civil
societies like Alejandra majorcus and
the Attorney General of warned us
they are so powerful that courts and
legislators bow before their rage
prosecutors can't even restrain them but
instead do their bidding why
because they're afraid not to do you
remember what the Maga people did to
Minneapolis when a jury dared to convict
their spiritual leader Derek Chauvin the
Maga people stormed the jail freed
Chopin They Carried him on their
shoulders back to their gorilla camps in
the mountains where they danced
triumphantly before bonfires made of
back issues of the Atlantic magazine
howling into the night sky and then as
an indelible lesson to the rest of us
they returned to the City of Minneapolis
and sacked it because that's what they
do when they don't agree with the jury
decision they Riot that's what the mega
people are like and that's where the
greatest threat we face do you remember
that moment we saved the tape ladies and
gentlemen hear the Maga people
everybody out here enjoying their silver
we love being together as a family
we play more but it's stomach turning
Ash ginsaki would look like she's never
recovered from it subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight